[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros y
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con los 25 de
noviembre se celebra el día
internacional de la eliminación de la
violencia contra la mujer onu mujeres
advirtió que la pandemia de coronavirus
se sigue causando estragos y también
acentúa los problemas sociales y que
puede afectar a décadas y avances para
las mujeres y para la igualdad de género
por ello hoy nos acompaña mariano el
baeza ella es la directora para las
américas y el caribe de la agencia de la
onu para las mujeres con mujeres gracias
por estar con nosotros señora maría noel
en baeza con la pandemia de koi 19 las
cifras de violencia doméstica en todo el
mundo se incrementaron cuanto empeoró la
situación de las mujeres en el planeta
muy buenos días y muchas gracias por
invitarme al programa y ha aumentado
muchísimo en los primeros días de la
pandemia podemos decir hasta ahora que
el 80% de aumento se ha dado en las
llamadas de pedido de ayuda todavía no
tenemos las cifras de los feminicidios
pero calculamos que va a ser al menos un
30% más que el año pasado que fueron
4.000 mujeres que han muerto en nuestra
región a causa de ser mujeres por
feminicidio la violencia está tomando
distintas raíces como por ejemplo como
en este tiempo de pandemia nos hemos
movido al mundo cibernético la violencia
ha aumentado hasta 300 por ciento en el
ciberespacio tenemos lamentablemente que
decir que la violencia contra la mujer
es una pandemia en la sombra en nuestra
región por eso es que insistimos la
necesidad de mantener los servicios
esenciales que requiere la mujer
violentada a la mujer
como por ejemplo los refugios tener
servicios esenciales de salud que deben
de ser mantenidos y por eso les pedimos
a los presidentes la región su voluntad
política para declarar la violencia
contra la mujer una emergencia eso es lo
que estamos solicitando en este 25 de
noviembre y nuestro secretario general
de las naciones unidas antonio guterres
también hizo un llamado a una estrategia
de voluntad política para el digamos
estar todos juntos luchando contra este
fenómeno
mariah cuáles son los focos rojos en
américa latina y cuál es la violencia
más común hacia hacia las mujeres la
violencia más común hacia las mujeres
desafortunadamente está en el hogar está
en la relación de pareja
esa es la violencia más común pero la
violencia se da durante toda la vida
durante todos los espacios
lamentablemente también tenemos un
crecimiento del acoso laboral un
crecimiento del acoso callejero
en el transporte público y entonces
tenemos un continuo de violencia los
países que más tasas de feminicidio
tienen por 100.000 mujeres son el
salvador-honduras bolivia guatemala y la
república dominicana estos países tienen
tasas de feminicidios muy altas pero el
fenómeno se da también en argentina en
uruguay en chile en su mexico muchísimo
en brasil o sea es un fenómeno en toda
la región
mariah y cómo hacer para cambiar esa esa
mentalidad machista que lamentablemente
se mantiene en nuestra región bueno hay
muchas innovaciones muy interesantes y
ayer las escuchábamos en un evento que
organizamos en colombia por ejemplo
están haciendo una escuela para
desestructurar el machismo están
hablando con los hombres hablando con
los jóvenes para ver cómo ese machismo
se erradica porque este es un primer
paso muy importante no normativo no las
normas sociales que son permisivas
muchas veces de la violencia entonces
hay que ver cómo se llega a eso
es tan importante trabajar con los
hombres y con los adolescentes en primer
lugar esto es prevención prevención en
la educación también de las niñas porque
muchas veces las niñas no saben que
están siendo violentadas por eso tan
importante la educación para erradicar
la violencia desde muy pequeñas
otro tema es establecer servicios
esenciales a disposición de las mujeres
muchas veces las mujeres no tienen donde
ir no tienen medios económicos porque
son totalmente dependientes del
depredador que su pareja que viven en su
casa por eso los refugios son tan
importantes y por supuesto la atención
en salud primaria así es maría
muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos en
su programa para hablar de un tema tan
interesante que nos aqueja a todos cómo
es la violencia contra la mujer que hay
que erradicarla por supuesto de nuestras
sociedades muchísimas gracias también
ustedes por estar en nuestro programa
hace una próxima oportunidad
[Música]